hello boys and girls of Earth it is
Jerry I'm back in action it's 2015 and
I'm here to talk to you yes--you about a
film I saw not long ago so recently a
couple weeks ago now I saw a new film
that some of y'all might not have heard
of okay this film there's Sun in my eyes
okay so this film this is the newest
movie by the spierig brothers and if you
don't know the spirit brothers
you should I'm a big fan of these guys
work there are a couple brothers from
Australia a few years back they made
sort of sci-fi zombie crossover flick
lots of humor very fun strange little
movie called undead one of the best
zombie kills ever is in that movie so
check it out it's a lot of fun it's it's
you know rough around the edges but it's
a good time and then they also did a
movie that you might have seen from a
couple years ago I think 2007 called day
breakers which had Ethan Hawke and Sam
Neill and a couple other people and set
in the future where you know vampires
are the majority of the world now you
know human beings are an endangered
species and the vampires are farming the
remaining humans but they're running out
of blood very cool concept and I got to
say first and foremost what I love about
these two guys is that you know in their
productions their movies they're really
good at drawing very detailed worlds
they're really good at coming up with
these interesting concepts and then
fleshing them out into very rich worlds
you can tell they've thought of all the
possibilities and the designs are great
and whatnot and this new movie
predestination is no exception it's very
different again from their other work
you know they seem to be jumping around
to different ideas and stuff like that
but it's still firmly planted in science
fiction
so this is a movie that expands upon a
short story by Robert Heinlein who wrote
the story that became Starship Troopers
and all that so this guy is a science
fiction author kind of contentious in
the sense that he might not be a great
person but his sci-fi is good and these
guys have taken it and expanded upon it
and made this movie predestination it
takes place in a sort of futuristic
version of the 80s and to describe it is
kind of hard because if you sum it up if
you like sum up the logline it kind of
sounds like Minority Report and it kind
of sounds like much more of an action
movie that it is because Ethan Hawke
works for this Bureau of the government
that specializes in like crime
prevention and time-travel so he travels
the time into specific places and
basically works to apprehend criminals
before they can you know do with the
crimes and that's sort of the wallpaper
but this movie is much more personal
than that and much more of a mind bender
than that I mean that's the that's sort
of the set up of who Ethan Hawke is he's
an agent of this ranch however so much
of this film is very personal and it
rests a lot of it rests on his co-star
Sarah snook who was in jessebella back
in October and she stars opposite Easton
Hawk in this and I have to tell you this
is the first movie I have knowingly seen
her in and she is [ __ ] incredible she
is so good in this movie and Ethan Hawke
is great too and I know some people
complain that while Daybreakers is a
really cool concept and a really cool
story you know somebody acting as a bit
green and I think the spirits are
getting better at directing actors now
because you know like the first time
they're on screen together they start
talking and the scene goes on for a few
minutes and I was sitting there going oh
they're actually having a conversation
they're not just you know skipping the
plot points right away and I think
that's why this movie got dumped into
January because you know January gets
[ __ ] on a lot of the time January
February movies because it's sort of the
dumping ground for the movies that you
know Studios now aren't gonna do very
well or they know aren't very good or
whatnot but I've come to appreciate
January lately because it's also the
place where Studios seem to cram
these strange little films they don't
quite know what to do with it's like I
love the gray and the gray came out in
January and the gray was a movie that
the studio's didn't quite know how to
sell didn't know what to do it and this
is one of those you know rare little
nuggets you get in the beginning of the
year where it's like man it's strange so
I get that they didn't know what to do
with it necessarily but it's awesome I'm
so glad it's here I mean this movie is
very inventive and it's it's science
fiction but it's a little more heady
science fiction and it's a very personal
science fiction it's not about
explosions and alien fights and whatnot
this movie is sort of combination sci-fi
combination period piece some of it's
sort of a crime thriller but it works in
so many different levels and Sarah snook
has to play so many different versions
of this character and the places the
story goes and I don't want to ruin any
of them because they're I don't want to
ruin any other place that this story
goes because it's just it would be to do
it the movie a disservice you know part
of the fun is the surprises and stuff
like that and the certain twists you can
pick out in certain twists you can't and
there is so much going on here that just
isn't what you normally see and Sarah
Snow has to play oh such a wide range of
people because it really is her story
it's a very personal story to that
character and she has to play a woman a
man a young version of herself an older
version of herself and and she and Ethan
Hawke have incredible chemistry and Noah
Taylor's also in this and and and Sarah
snuke and Noah Taylor Ethan Hawke and
Noah Taylor get to play off each other
as well and they have a good screen
chemistry and this movie I mean again
it's very different from undead it's
very different from Daybreakers but it
is again so rich in how well they draw
the details of this world ending all the
different places it goes because this
movie is sort of like I said it's a
period piece it jumps throughout
different parts of history and it's also
sort of an alternative history so the
aesthetics are really cool and the sort
of trappings of this sort of time travel
story are really cool and interesting
and it's it's kind of a loaf I science
fiction story in a sense I mean it's not
you just gotta say yeah so I can't
recommend this movie enough especially
in January it's it's it's one of the
rare nuggets of a really cool film that
comes out in January so if you can check
it out please do it's really cool I
think the the writing is good the acting
is great and I think the spirits are
again getting better and more
sure-footed and and you know they're
kind of Renaissance men because they
write and direct together I know at
least one of them works on the score
they both do visual effects and whatnot
they do the editing I think they really
craft their movies I get the sense and I
really like what they do so I'm always
looking forward to seeing them around
and it was nice to to have them back
again after so long
so yeah predestination is the movie
definitely check it out if you can
really cool different sci-fi film and
I'm just so glad it's here I wish we
could see more sci-fi movies like this
so yeah it's a good question what's it
what's a sci-fi story you've read maybe
a short story or a novel or something
like that that it's maybe off the beaten
path that you would love to see made
into a movie let's talk about that
so yeah until next time leave some
comments in the comment section be kind
to your fellow coming tears and until
next time I am Jerry the movies
predestination the shears